[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the life of aberforth
dumbledore younger brother of the great
and powerful wizard albus dumbledore
while his life may not have been as
widely celebrated as his older brothers
aberforth experienced his own share of
adventures and tragedy throughout his
life born sometime between 1883 and 1884
to percival and kendra dumbledore
aberforth was a half-blood wizard and
the dumbledore's second-born son
his older brother was as mentioned the
world famous albus dumbledore when the
brothers were still quite young they
were joined by the little sister mariana
whom aberforth was extremely fond of
in the beginning the dumbledore family
lived quite a normal wizarding life in
the village of mold on the world their
mother would read them bedtime stories
from the classic book for young witches
and wizards the tales of beedle the bard
and aberforth and ariana would feed the
goats together with a somewhat peculiar
interest in goats aberforth's favorite
tale was as you might expect grumble the
grubby goat in fact if you'd like to
learn more on the subject of aberforth
and his obsession with goats i highly
recommend you check out my other video
what did before dumbledore do with goats
anyway despite not being terribly
interested in academics aberforth
attended hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry between 1895 and 1902
unfortunately it was while he was away
at school that his beloved younger
sister was attacked by three muckle boys
who came across her practicing magic
ariana who was only six years old at the
time was never the same again
unfortunately the tragedy didn't stop
there after the attack percival
dumbledore went after the boys cursing
them for the trauma they had caused his
daughter
apprehended by the wizarding authorities
percival refused to reveal why he'd
attacked the mughals for fear the truth
would result in ariana being taken away
to live out the remainder of her life in
saint mungo's hospital for magical
maladies and injuries this was a
legitimate fear as ariana's magic had
become quite uncontrollable in her
attempt to suppress it after the attacks
it's very likely that she would have
been viewed as a threat to the wizarding
world's statute of secrecy
sadly percival was sentenced to life in
azkaban never to return to his family as
he later died in prison after percival's
conviction kendra moved the family to
godric's hollow concealing ariana's
condition from the rest of the village
in fact appleforth and albus were
instructed by their mother to tell
anyone who asked after ariana that she
was quite ill and needed to stay home
as this kept her out of sight and away
from hogwarts many witches and wizards
incorrectly assumed that ariana was a
squib however if anything it's much more
likely that she was an obscurial that is
a young witch who had suppressed her
powers due to shame from a traumatic
event which then became a dark
parasitical form of uncontrollable magic
despite all this aberforth and ariana
remained incredibly close
he helped their mother care for her when
he was home from school and the two
siblings would continue to feed the
goats together i could get her to eat
when she wouldn't do it for my mother i
could calm her down when she was in one
of her rages and when she was quiet she
used to help me feed the goats
aberforth was so involved in ariana's
care that he was completely devastated
by the fact that he wasn't there the day
she lost control and accidentally killed
their mother during one of her fits he
believed that if only he'd been there he
may have been able to prevent this
tragedy from happening after the death
of their mother aberforth did not want
to return to hogwarts as he wanted to be
the one to care for ariana
however being that he had not graduated
school and albus had his older brother
refused to let him sacrifice his
education and forced him to return to
hogwarts even though he himself was
immensely resentful of the duty that was
thrust upon him then he met gelat
grindelwald and was seduced into the
pursuit of the deathly hallows and a
vision of conquering muggles aberforth
was horrified before even though he was
a gruff peculiar young wizard he was
also a very decent person it would seem
that he never held any prejudice against
muggles despite what had happened to his
sister which meant that he thought a
plan to force them into servitude was
disturbing indeed he was also intensely
concerned for ariana's well-being if
albus was planning to travel the globe
and overthrow the entire mughal
population while also caring for their
sister she would clearly be in immense
danger and so aberforth bravely although
some may say foolishly confronted albus
and grindelwald this was the
confrontation which resulted in the
tragic death of ariana
despite this tragedy being the result of
a random curse the source of the spell
remaining a mystery even to this day
appleforth blamed albus for her death he
even punched albus in the face at
ariana's funeral breaking his nose and
signifying the end of their somewhat
already strained relationship as ab
fourth grew into adulthood he gained a
reputation as a wizard who was not a
people person
in fact in any disagreement he much
preferred to duel rather than debate and
he was known to occasionally fling goat
dung at those who opposed him in an
argument he was not particularly
interested in academics and he pursued a
lifelong career as the barkeep and
landlord of the hogshead inn in
hogsmeade the all-wizarding village
close to hogwarts in the gobber to fire
albus even suggested that aberforth may
have been illiterate although i think
this was simply albus's particular brand
of humor since we know that aberforth
attended hogwarts and therefore had had
an education
in any case aberforth was a powerful and
talented wizard although i suppose he
was somewhat lacking in comparison to
his older brother during the first
wizarding war aberforth joined the
original order of the phoenix he did so
despite the group being founded and led
by albus which further proves that amber
forth was willing to overlook personal
vendettas if it pertained to the
betterment of the wizarding world
that said aberforth was no stranger to
holding a grudge after all his
relationship with albus never fully
healed from their fallout from ariana's
death it was also known that he proudly
barred the wizard wandungus fletcher
from entering the hog's head after a
particularly notable disagreement he
also once threw severus snape out of the
inn when he realized that snape was
eavesdropping on albus interview with
professor trulorney the one in which he
revealed the prophecy about harry potter
and lord voldemort despite his rough
nature towards other witches and wizards
however aberforth maintained a
noteworthy interest in goats throughout
his life so much so that his patronus
was a goat and he was even prosecuted
for practicing an inappropriate charm on
one drawing official censure from
whizzing gamut the wizarding high court
of law in britain that said jk rowling
has made reference to aberforth's goat
obsession over the years and insists
that his interest in this animal was
completely innocent following albus
death aberforth attended his brother's
funeral despite their damage
relationship after all albus had been
aberforth's last remaining relative and
they had managed to at least maintain
contact over the years as headmaster and
barkeep throughout the harry potter
series we don't see too much of amber
forth until the final installment of
this series
as harry ron and hermione searched for
voldemort's horcraxes aberforth supplied
food and water to dumbledore's army
through a secret passage that led to
hogwarts room of requirement
in homage to his sister this passageway
remained hidden behind a portrait of
ariana he also sent dobby the house elf
to rescue harry and the others from
bellatrix to strange at malfoy manor
after hearing harry ask for help through
the two-way mirror that once belonged to
sirius black aberforth was able to
protect harry ron and hermione from
being taken by death eaters in hogsmeade
convincing voldemort's followers that
they had seen his goat patronus not
harry's famous stag after which harry
was able to relay how much regret albus
had carried around with him for his
entire life over feeling responsible for
their sister's death
from there aberforth was convinced to
help the trio get into hogwarts so that
they could try and find the dark lord's
remaining horcruxes he then fought
alongside harry hogwarts staff and
students and members of the revived
order of the phoenix in the battle of
hogwarts after surviving the battle it
is said that he continued to live out
his life in hogsmeade with his goats in
terms of his appearance he is described
in harry potter as follows harry
approached him looking up into the face
trying to see past the long stringy wiry
gray hair and beard
he wore spectacles behind the dirty
lenses the eyes were a piercing
brilliant blue of course from what we
can see in the trailer of the secrets of
dumbledore aberforth appears as a much
younger wizard with darker hair that's
been cropped short aside from his
appearance it's possible that this new
film will also reveal some new facts
about aberforth's life how exciting and
with that we have come to the end of
another video did you enjoy learning
about aberforth dumbledore's life did i
miss anything of great importance any
theories on what we'll learn about him
in the secrets of dumbledore let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel until next time
memory is everything
you